series and sequences so far we've looked
at just the whole idea in general of a
set of numbers that have some kind of
order to them right that's what
distinguishes these from sets we've also
looked at specific kinds of serious
secretive and the two kinds work
remember
geometric and half-minute
right and it's the difference is how do
these sequences go from term to term
I have they get bigger and smaller is
that a constant difference or is it a
constant ratio okay so now you've got
all the pieces and the formulas we're
now going to have a look at how this
uses equals as a PR in real life okay
and the most obvious one is in money
so let's revise before we actually get
to the applications to money situations
of like I also think back to the
different kinds of interests that you
can get two kinds of you chose right if
you are trying to earn money you put
money into a bank now the first kind of
interest is called
simple alright which I had a call it's
in interest I call it silly interest
because there is not an institution in
the world that actually pays interest in
this way we just we just know at first
because it's mathematically simple so
how does have a simple interest work if
you wanted to work out the interest of a
certain amount of money put into an
account what's the name my way would you
put my into account get a name it's
called principle ready so if you're
trying to work out the interest on a
principle that's got a certain rate say
R for a certain amount of time they like
any years or something like that what
was the formula I can't get there just
its own if you remember think back to
you rate it some just multiply through
write the principal times whatever your
rate is assuming that you know like say
for 8% I guess that'll be 1.08 so that
it gets no it sorry that's wrong it's
point zero because I'm just
times however long you're in there for
this is that okay so if for instance if
I start with thousand dollars I had been
there for eight percent interest so zero
zero and we had in there for like 20
years
okay twenty times that would be midpoint
there in one point six so you get sixty
degree of interest right and I guess you
would add that onto the original $1000
so $2,600 be your mouth now of course
like we said that's not how interest
really works in the real world what's
the name of normal interest we have
compound interest rate the idea being as
you add interest on you get interest on
the interest as well that's why it's
compounded right what was the formula
for compound interest I did start with
an I started with an a a final amount of
you what do we would have after the
again start with your principal right
but then you multiply instead of just
multiply through by the numbers you've
got to raise to a power so it's one plus
your weight ^ however long you have in
there right so instead of this kind of
thing here you have for instance $1000
times now one plus R is why have 1.08
that's why I was getting confused with
before and it's just this part that we
raise to the power of well twenty I
guess because I'm after first see R
multiply once and then the second year I
multiply again and again and again and
by the end of 2005 now I this is all
fine so far if we've just got a
situation where you stick the money in
the account and then you walk away
you do nothing by the way what we call
this kinds of accounts where you stick
money in and you don't touch it and
you're allowed to touch it or they call
most people don't have these admittedly
they attract a higher interest rate the
cool term just term deposits is that
ring a bell
okay so you stick your money in a don't
touch it and that's what's going to
happen - it will just increase in
whatever the interest rate but in the
real world heart usually we don't have
ten deposits usually money's going here
and coming out we're actually making
withdrawals and deposits all the time
right so let's consider and you make a
new subheading so this is not simple
interest in the revision on compound
interest anymore let's look at
investment okay now um before I get into
it I'm going to tell you right off the
bat the main example of investment we
talk about is superannuation so as I go
through this example I'm going to keep
referring back to how superannuation
works because well most of you don't
have jobs and even if you do a lot of
people have jobs and never think about
how this works so I'm going to try to
draw pals with this and how the sources
okay
so let's consider a man and here invests
let's call it a seven hundred fifty
dollars every year so I guess we could
say he's investing it into well it could
be just a banking huh but this is the
way superannuation funds work your
employer or the government rather takes
money out of your paycheck you never get
it I'm gonna get to see it because it
goes straight into what we call
superannuation fund um takes out this
amount and sticks it into account that's
good
interest for you you can only get out of
her time every year in puts that amount
in but every year it's also any interest
okay so let's just go with this right
here which is only interest at eight
percent per annum now you guys know by
the way this is not enough information
to work out how much he's going to earn
because as well as knowing the interest
rate what else do you need to know you
need to know how frequently something
compounds right and we've looked at
exercise before where the more
frequently you compound the the more
money make right just for the sake of
simplicity let's just call it annually
okay so here's my question I think over
20 years before okay um how much will he
have after 20 years now there's a few
different ways to approach this question
just for the sake of not confusing you
I'm just going to show you one today so
you don't get on your wireless cross I
will show you other ones in subsequent
lessons I think eating this first method
of working out what's what's going to
happen to this is to imagine that there
are 20 years right and so I want you to
consider 20 Watts off is $750 okay this
this wasn't intuitive to me when I first
learnt it but if you have $750 here and
seven dollars here and they both earning
interest at the same
there's no difference from this to
having both of them in the same place
earning 80% I don't know if that gels
with your head yeah like huh really
wouldn't it make more sense if you get
all together and that earns more money
it doesn't I can crunch the numbers for
you later but for now just trust me and
I'm one I'm going to treat all of these
$750 what's the V investments I'm going
to treat all 20 of them separately okay
so let's just ignore that for a second
now coming back to these are different
ones let's consider the first amount
that first $750 that he sticks in there
based on our compound interest formula
we should know just think about this one
forgetting about all the other seven and
view dollar business we should be able
to work out how much that 750 is worth
after 20 years right because that's the
situation we started with it's like 750
and then I just put there and I don't
touch it
okay what's it worth after 20 years is
equal to principal times there's how
simple sorry is that compound interest
all right so I'm just going to stick my
numbers in right 750 times this is our
1.08 ^ 20 because it's in there for 20
years because I put it in right start
and it's there all the way to the end so
there's so we get off that now what
about the second law next year you puts
in another 750 when you compare to the
first slot because you put in one year
later instead of getting 20 lots of
interest added on to it
you only get 19 right so skipping the
formula because I can see the pattern
that's happening right this is very 7:55
your interest just by 19
okay now you start to establish a
pattern here is not that complicated
the next one's going to be 18 in 17
what will the last one be at the
beginning of the 20th year is 13 7 15 at
the end of the 20th year
what will it be where begin in the end
of the fitter than a whole year so I
guess it's going to get not 20 or 19 but
just one lot of the interest that okay
so the last 70 dollars just one okay now
I wonder if you were thinking of the
Munich what a superannuation have to do
with Syrian sequences can you see what
it has to do with series and sequences i
won
the question was how much total value
right and therefore I need to take all
of these lots of 750 dollars on which
there are 20 and out of a lot right so I
can write it like this total is equal to
I could write each one individually but
I can see there's a common factor here
namely the principles are saying every
single time so I can put the 750 at the
front and then what am I going to have
afterwards well my first lot my first
investment will be this many lots of 750
and my next one will be this many lines
and then we go and my last one be worth
that okay now if you've got another
color there this will help you
I don't this part here is the bit were
interested in right now just keep in
mind by the way this series is the same
whether I look at it going 20 19 18
or when other one or if I look at it the
other way around the Sun is still a
sailor agreement that yeah the reason
why I'm going to think about it started
here is because we usually think about
series getting bigger right and will be
your pennies if for a numbers so kicking
your other color okay what I'd like you
to say is this is a GP where okay well
that's three pieces of a GP that define
a DVD right you've got your first term
the common ratio and then how many terms
there are actually in the whole series
okay remember I'm just thinking about
starting over here what's the first time
it's just one point away what's the
common ratio also how many terms are
there in total
don't forget someone so if I just go one
did you approach them
this is caddy numbers so I mean 20 now
just before I go any further
um this step here right do you have to
do this especially when you start to get
very familiar with this process you want
to skip out on this highly recommend you
don't reason why is because these
numbers are really easy okay sometimes
especially this end here but sometimes
the N we want less sometimes will be one
more and it's really confusing as to
which one it is okay if you don't
explicitly state which one is you often
get it wrong and then trick with it is
what a net effect will have later on if
I got this number wrong say say I
actually said 19 instead of 20 okay well
your numbers will all be just slightly
off like by the end you be like $10 off
something like that all your bucking
will check out and look really good when
you're going back to your exam you'll be
doing your own you can check it for
errors and everything is fine okay
because you know you didn't have this
step so you just went straight to your
actual work so because it's such an easy
error to miss as I recommend doing this
explicit step
okay so therefore if that's what this
whole series is equal to in that equal
sign down oh you guys know what this sum
of a GP is right the sum of a GP is
first time times which I should be going
with you probably PR first rank is ours
bigger than one minus one and now that
I've laid out all my pieces I can say
exactly what that's equal to I need your
calculator after this one it's 750 by
okay a 1.8 and you above 1.08 20 plus 1
all over zero so that okay now from
there you know where was where was the
GP Park it was just it's just if you
write getting setting this series up and
then work out where is equal to this
part is just calculator well okay
however still be careful there's lots of
little ways you can get into strife here
so watch out for your brac some of that
kind of thing and you get your answer
out at the end
pick it something like 37 yeah okay yeah
okay so there you go there's a pretty
typical question um what you got given
was how much was put in every off how
much interest it was earning and how
long
and then we generated what was the final
amount okay now by the way all of these
steps here okay I'm trying to emphasize
be explicit put everything there what
additional reasons why even though it
takes a while to write this all out
can you imagine
instead of 750 every year for 20 years
in like the middle here he wins a
lottery and gets like $3,000 extra every
year something like that right now if
you know that and you have all of this
setup you can add that in will come into
somewhere in the middle okay and your
subsequent working will take that into
account for some of the methods that
hesitate some of the team faces will get
you from here to here faster but only if
it's all nice and neat and there aren't
any weird things that happen in the
middle okay well you know if you like
has to buy your card so it comes in
seven or fifty anymore whatever it
changes in some way okay so do the
pattern completely so that you get if
there's any adjustments you can see how
it affects your work no matter
okay now I'll follow up with a question
get you guys to think about this I told
you in the question we got given
principal rate and how long right and
you had to work out the final amount
well a changeable
what if our arm have picture man wants
it end up with not 37 man but take a pee
break so instead of asking you to find a
I'm giving you a assuming the same
principle and the same interest rate how
long will that take
so what you have to think about all that
I've shown you how I set up the question
you're trying to find the different
variables so obviously it's not going to
go exactly the same okay I think you
have enough sort of algebraic chops to
try and handle out well how am I going
to find
that's my question okay have you